bon un peu tourner pour la majorité
présidentielle ça va vous avez raison
pendant toute une période ils ont réussi
à faire croire ça assez bien fonctionné
qu'en politique l'expérience était
devenue une tard et que il fallait
absolument dégager tout le monde
remplacer ceux qui avaient un peu ou
beaucoup d'expérience par de jeunes
néophytes qui allaient révolutionné le
tout on a vu ce que ça donne à
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'on a
quand même quelques exemples de députés
qui sont passés surprenants ici au Sénat
je pense que il se produira pas la même
chose d'abord parce que le Sénat n'est
pas le clone de l'Assemblée nationale le
corps électoral ce sont des élus locaux
en très grande majorité et c'est élus
locaux aussi envie d'être représentés
par des gens qui connaissent le sujet
parce que la société civile n'a pas sa
place au Sénat mais la société civile
vous savez dans les élus locaux il y a
beaucoup de voilà qu'est-ce que c'est
que la société civile est-ce que vous
croyez que tous les conseils municipaux
de France sont des gens qui ne font que
de la politique à plein-temps c'est pas
vrai et donc ces élus là veulent être
représent par des gens qui connaissent
leurs difficultés quand vous n'avez
jamais géré une commune un département
une intercommunalité qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez véritablement du fond des
problèmes donc je pense que ça les élus
locaux ils sont particulièrement
sensibles et puis comme le disait Elian
assassin les annoncent du président de
la République ne peuvent que perturber
grandement les élus locaux exemple les
dotations le président de la République
il n'y aura pas de baisse de dotation
tout le monde dit ah superbe mais il dit
en même temps comme d'habitude
d'ailleurs en même temps on va vous
demander 13 milliards d'euros
d'économies ah et alors si les économies
ne sont pas au rendez-vous bah on va
nous baisser les dotations on a bien
compris donc en 2018 on nous dit ça sera
la stabilisé la stabilité mais tout le
monde a compris qu'à partir de 2019 pour
nous imposer effectivement les 13
milliards il va falloir réduire les
dotations donc on a perdu 11 milliards
sous le quinquennat Hollande on va
ajouter 13 milliards mais tous les élus
locaux savent que c'est intenable pour
l'immense majorité des collectivités
donc bon alors on peut parler des
contrats aidés les crédits de la
politique de la ville qui réalité réduit
comme ça d'un coup de baguette magique
vous savez dans un département comme la
Seine-Saint-Denis la politique de la
ville s'apaise donc vous mettez tout ça
sur la table mais comment voulez-vous
réagissent les grands électeurs alors
c'est vrai que les candidats de la
République en marche ils sont à la peine
et j'espère bien qu'effectivement leurs
résultats sera à la hauteur de l'immense
déception de ceux qui avaient pu croire
en eux